[Music]
foreign
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something that obviously isn't dead
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
boom
you built such a beautiful life filled
with love and family I never got a
chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
by peace
[Music]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan dog I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
[Music]
for accept death when suffering is old
it's set up
he's trying to tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raised for respect
[Music]
today
the problem with having such a big
family how do you choose the ones you
save
Let's Race
[Music]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime here we go
game recognizes again
[Music]
I'm coming for you son
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
oh
[Music]
my God
[Applause]
I'm learning sunshine sunshine you gotta
be kidding me
[Music]
laughs